you know I've been playing music game
since way before music games were cool
and now that stuff like guitar hero rock
bands everybody's got to get into the
end but on this week's show we're going
to talk about to really interesting
things first the university professor
just developed version of guitar hero
that can be played by the line and
second the ultimate casual game is
finally available on the opening casual
game system rock bands out this week on
the wii and that's all this week game
line
so we're here with Elka Fullmer and he
is a professor at university of nevada
in reno and doing some really
fascinating research actually on video
games for the blind and disabled so Elka
why don't you tell me what it is I'm
hooked up to here we developed a glove
with little pays for instance and that
sweets finger that allows a blind person
to play guitar hero guitar hero depends
upon visual stimulus you see like notes
running down the screen and if you're
blind because you can't see anything so
we had the idea of like you know
transforming a visual stimulus into
haptic feedback so we thought about
creating a glove with little face your
engines like patrons you can find in
cell phones but these are kind of like
industrial base your engines they have a
little bit more vibration and we texted
to his finger and basically whenever you
feel your finger buzzing you have to
press the note and it's how a blind
person can play guitar hero alright so
if I close my eyes and uh you know look
elsewhere I can totally play this yeah
all right and you're using a frets on
fire yeah get some sources of course we
don't have to go to guitar hero Sarah
you just use open source version and
yeah just proves if we can modify
existing games rather than like having
to go to games from scratch
you know it's interesting because it
really it is really difficult to play
this your fingers start vibrating a
little bit and then immediately
afterwards you've got to hit the button
and I think it is one of those things
that people who are blind if you are
visually impaired to probably have an
easier time with just because they're so
used to using their sense of touch to do
things very going at one now I let's say
you know I wanted to actually you know
play a blind hero essentially for myself
I mean you're kind of working on ways to
get it out to the public we wish the
only problems like these gloves we have
two and the cuss 1500 Allah sees to
develop and yeah I would really it would
be really nice if we could find a
producer or something that bit that be
able to create something or maybe we can
actually because a glove is kind of a
hard solution we would ideally would
want to have a solution that works with
you witty or is you know I guitar hero
so I don't know maybe we can construct
the guitar with little pacer answers in
there and find some way to control that
of course we need support from game
developers to do that well it's all very
fascinating stuff you're doing amazing
work so thank you very much for being
here it's been really great thanks rock
band a four-player music game that lets
drummers and guitarist and vocalist all
come together to create the ultimate
full band experience was one of the
breakout hits of last year's holiday
season unless of course you owned we in
which case you were completely shut out
but never fear rock band is finally
coming out for the wii it's available
this week and we have got it and we
checked it out just for you
in their minds the Blitzkrieg
art bell in the backseat they generate
steam heat through the fat feed the
blitzkrieg bop now if you've never heard
of rock band before you have probably
been living in a cave and I kind of feel
sorry for you but I'll run it down for
you at two players grab guitar
controllers and start jamming out to the
notes that are on the left and right
hand side of the screens there in the
middle the identical line of notes
that's for the drummer so you sit down
in front of the game's plastic drum set
and start wailing away like you're one
of the Ramones and then somebody else
can now grab a microphone and start
singing the song and everybody gets
graded differently and as a band and so
it really encourages cooperative music
gameplay it's just that easy rock band
for the wii is actually closer to the
PlayStation 2 version of MTV's game that
it is to the xbox and ps3 editions you
can't design your own custom rockers and
there's no online play you also cannot
download new songs every week like you
can in the next-gen versions up but they
will be releasing song pack discs in
stores with a whole bunch of new songs
on them starting in July for the
gameplay rocks just as hard and the
instrument controllers are just as good
in fact there's a little minor
improvement to the drum controllers down
here the support poles here are plastic
not metal which makes the whole unit way
a little less and look they're squared
off at the ends which means that we can
do this and the pedal doesn't fall off
which is a huge annoyance with the with
the xbox 360 version now up the guitar
controllers are wireless although there
is a catch you have to plug this USB
dongle into the back of your way one for
each guitar the drums and microphone are
wired but you can use any USB microphone
and that's pretty much rock band we in a
nutshell it's kind of disappointing that
it's a part of the PlayStation 2 verse
of the game so it doesn't have all the
extra features of the xbox 360
playstation 3 versions but it does
actually have five extra bonus songs
just for the wii version like the
police's Roxanne and the b-52s Rome so
you know it kind of evens out okay not
really but sort of but you know what i
think we owners are going to be happy
that their system finally has the
rockingest game of the year